Leute es ist soweit gute Neuigkeiten
meine Krankenkasse übernimmt ein Teil
meiner Augenoperation und bald habe ich
auch ohne Brille sehen
ich glaube wir befinden uns heute in
einer Premiere das muss ich jetzt selber
auf meinem Kanal recherchieren es ist
eine Premiere und damit herzlich
willkommen Leute mein Name ist Vanessa
und ich führe euch heute durch den
Adventskalender 2022 von Lush letztes
Jahr habe ich ihn in einem Instagram
Livestream getestet dieses Jahr möchte
ich das auch auf meinem Kanal
präsentieren der Preis der Preis haut
rein ich glaube das ist mit einer der
teuersten Kalender die ich hier
ausgepackt habe Neos Mios 235 € kostet
dieses Paket aber wenn ihr mal bei La
Schwab wisst ihr diese Badekugeln und
Seifen und so die sind ja nicht so
günstig liegt auch daran dass es
handgemacht ist also was ich bei Lasche
mal ganz toll finde sind diese Sticker
dass du ganz genau weiß wer wann dieses
Ding abgepackt hat und bevor ich jetzt
100 mal Lush sage
dieses Video ist teilweise gesponsert
Lush hat mir diesen Adventskalender
zugeschickt vielen Dank an dieser Stelle
aber ich werde trotzdem ehrlich bewerten
gerade bei dem Preis ist es natürlich
wichtig zu sehen Arthouse unlimited
Licht ich möchte gerne
Heia okay also dieser Kalender wurde von
drei Künstlern gemalt Arthouse unlimited
präsentiert die künstlerischen Talente
von Erwachsenen mit neurodiversen und
körperlichen Unterstützungsbedarf die
Künstlerinnen arbeiten zusammen mit
Lehrkräften an der Erstellung von
Kunstwerken die zu Designprodukten für
den Verkauf weiterentwickelt werden alle
Künstlerinnen tragen mit ihrer
jeweiligen Fähigkeit zum gelingt das
Designs bei somit sind alle Beiträge von
besonderem Wert und außerordentlicher
Sinnhaftigkeit das ist toll das ist toll
es war so ganz toll da gehe ich gleich
mal auf die Lush Webseite und dann gucke
ich mal ob ich das bekomme was ich nicht
bezahlt habe ne ist dieser
Kalendereintrag hatte ich wirklich das
Gefühl
es riecht jetzt in meiner Wohnung dieser
Kalender riecht wirklich sehr sehr doll
und wir schauen einfach mal was drin ist
und ich würde ja nicht Vanessa heißen
wenn ich nicht Vanessa heißen würde ich
habe sogar Wasser mitgebracht also ich
bin jetzt
heute nicht dich durch den Kalender
führt das nicht toll okay let's go tau
ja also noch mal zum Preis ne das ist
wirklich Wahnsinn also ähm das ist für
mich halt so dieser Laden wo ich
wirklich so eine Badekugel dann zum
Verschenken oder wenn ich mir mal was
gönnen möchte kaufe bei 24 Produkten
steigt dann halt natürlich der Preis
ja wenn jedes Produkt ungefähr fast 10 €
Pro Türchen okay also ja ne warum habt
ihr da keine Preise zu den einzelnen
Produkten da muss ich das nicht immer
alles raussuchen
hier ist auf jeden Fall alles was drin
steckt ja richtig freaky das Designer
erinnert mich tatsächlich an NanuNana
ich war letztens dort und habe die neue
Weihnachtsdeko gesehen und irgendwie ist
man dieses Jahr in Neonfarben hängen
geblieben habe ich noch nie so gesehen
aber wahrscheinlich ist das neue Thema
wiederverwendbare Box die wirklich sehr
schön wieder verwendbar ist ne die ist
sehr sehr hochwertig aber wahrscheinlich
kann man auch schon für diese Box ein
paar Euro abziehen ne weil wenn man so
eine Box kauft das ist halt nichts
lasches
sollte zwar machen äh na die ist mit
Metall und ich habe die vom letzten Jahr
habe ich auch im Badezimmer stehen sehr
sehr praktisch ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen Angst dass wenn ich immer
positive Sachen sage dass ihr dann immer
gleich glaubt dass es ist weil ich die
Box geschenkt bekommen habe also glaubt
mir wenn ich euch ehrlich meine Meinung
zu dem Kalender sage okay wir müssen
jetzt dieses Vertrauensverhältnis
schaffen und dann wird das ein ganz
tolles Erlebnis hier vertrauen
[Musik]
und wir beginnen mit Türchen Nummer eins
und hier befindet sich Stroh warum hast
du eine Maske auf designmäßig mal was
ganz anderes als die anderen die erste
Badekugel überzeugt mit glitzernden
Sternchen ist da oben Christmas Party
die Christmas Party Badekugel riecht
nach oh die erinnert mich an irgendeine
Süßigkeit ich kann es aber nicht sagen
so jetzt finden wir mal raus was sind
diese Badekugel kostet
hä ich nehme eine ähnliche oh mein Gott
okay ich bin irgendwie falsch informiert
gewesen ich dachte eine Badebombe kostet
5 € eine Badebombe kostet 8 € hängt so
laut es ist eine sehr große Freude diese
Badekugel ich habe euch versprochen ich
bin ehrlich ja 8 € für eine Badekugel
ist viel Nummer zwei befindet sich
wieder Stroh drin oh yes das ist quasi
auch eine Badekugel aber mit dieser
festen Konsistenz und diese Badekugeln
die schäumen auch richtig da benutze ich
aber tatsächlich auch immer zwei
Portionen also die breche ich mir für
zwei Badeerlebnisse waren sparen sparen
als orange ist will ich das sagen dass
es noch irgendwie richtig das riecht
aber so nach Mandarine orange es riecht
auch wieder wie so eine Süßigkeit voll
schwierig ich will nicht auf die anderen
Sachen gucken also da hätte man es
besser machen können dass man wirklich
nacheinander dass man es schafft zu
sehen was man im Türchen hat ohne gleich
rein zu gucken und zu wissen was alles
andere ist ein Schaumbad ah das heißt
Schaumbad und man könnte den Duft einmal
beschreiben finde ich in diesem Buch
sind halt die Inhaltsstoffe drin aber so
eine kleine kurze Beschreibung das
riecht nach Orange Mandarine wäre gut
der Party popper ist weil es ein
Partyhut ist
7,50 € und deswegen kaufe ich das
Schaumbad immer lieber weil das schäumt
Schaum ist gut und das wirft man ja so
einmal rein und dann kostet das 8 € und
das kostet 57 und davon habe ich zweimal
was
oh oh oh ja es ist ein es ist ein es ist
ein Schaumbad meine meine Liebe
intensiver Kalender so wie riecht das
auch gut aber beeriger das riecht alles
ich habe so ich glaube ich habe einfach
sehr großen Hunger deswegen riecht das
alles extrem lecker nach Süßigkeiten
oh mein Gott es riecht wie von Katjes
die Gummi Einhörner aber auch ne das ist
riesengroß das würde ich dreimal
benutzen
9 Euro aber das ist auch ein bisschen
größer ne wir sind aber noch nicht so
Sachen die ich in meine Kleine Wanne
hier machen möchte die nächste Geburt
und was kommt da also
wir nehmen viel milder gar nicht nach
Katjes gar keine Süßigkeiten
aber ich glaube ich sag schon wieder
irgendeine Zitrusfrucht weil es gelbe
orange ist was sagen wir zum Motiv wir
haben immer ganz tolle Ideen ne das ist
ein Esel das Pferd achso ich muss es ja
nicht sagen ne aber alle sind vegan
gifthorst wenn man einem Pferdemädchen
eine Badebombe schenken möchte hätte ich
ein anderes Pferdemotiv genommen 6 €.
vielleicht mit meinen 5 € in meiner
Erinnerung ja doch ein bisschen richtig
eine Frage zum Thema Baden wenn ich bade
kann ich z.B um das Wasser zu sparen
meine Pflanzen danach damit Gießen nein
ne wegen dem Zeug was im Waschgel und so
drin ist ich spreche hier gerade zum
dritten Mal schon mein Opa an in den
Adventskalender Videos aber der hat
immer das Badewasser aufbewahrt und
damit die Toilette durchgespült ist
falls Ihr einen Tipp haben was man mit
benutzten Badewasser machen kann
schreibt gerne in die Kommentare und
jetzt geht's zur Türchen Nummer 5 also
Leute da hat sich der jetzt oh fühlt er
sich gut an der fühlt sich so richtig
fettig und ölig an da hat sich das ja
jetzt schnell hier Rainbow technisch
wiederholt
das riecht wie ein Rosenbad wie diese
eine Kugel ich würde euch gerne besser
beschreiben können wo ich eigentlich
Kaffee wie bei Lush weißt du die haben
immer so eine kaffeeschale dass man so
zwischendurch neutralisiert weil man so
viel riecht dass die Nase einfach
komplett verwirrt ist
[Musik]
Eis Rainbow ich finde den zwar nicht
aber da sie sich identisch sind 9 € und
hier haben wir wieder die Kategorie
glitzerst nach deinem Bad manchmal
machen wir sehr viel Glitzer dran
trägt deins
Nikolaus Türchen Nummer 6 da lasch eine
britische Firma ist vermutlich jetzt
gerade vermutlich nichts Besonderes
nichts Besonderes ja toll schön also
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht dann
riecht das schon wieder super lecker
weil so eine kleine Beschreibung wäre
schön gewesen Shampoos das und hier
gibt's auch eine benutzbeschreibung
Streich ein paar mal mit dem festen
Shampoo über das nasse Haar und reibe
ist zwischen deinen Händen und Schaum zu
erzeugen
asmr-mäßig wieder top und ich kenne die
festen Shampoos von Lush und ich finde
die sehr gut und sie riechen fantastisch
Shampoos von Lush allgemein finde ich
sehr gut also ich hatte mir immer mal
wieder eins gekauft und so Kokos und so
das riecht nach Zitrone
12 Euro das würde mich mal interessieren
für wie viele Haarwäschen das ist wow
wow und ich muss vor allem gucken wie
ich die Badekugeln für die Verlosung
einpacke wahrscheinlich so ein Papier
oder so ne Nummer 7
ich vermute schon mal das ist aha aha
aha die berühmte goldene Birne richtig
jetzt auch wieder lecker es wäre
wirklich sehr ironisch wenn die jetzt
nicht lecker riechen würde ne
was ist eine Seife keine Badebombe eine
Seife mit sehr viel auch Gold und wieder
drumrum ich frage mich ob das an den
Händen bleibt also es riecht nicht so
lecker wie die anderen Sachen schade 12
€. okay ja aber leider ne bei einem
Produkt was 12 € kostet es ist
handgemacht ich verstehe es aber so also
er hat rutscht hier so das ist nicht gut
verbaut das ist nicht deutsche
Ingenieurskunst hier die hier sehe
Nummer 8 das wäre doch gelacht oh das
sieht schon wieder aus wie was zu essen
ich muss mir auch angewöhnen zu
frühstücken vor diesem Video ich bin zu
hungrig das funktioniert so nicht also
für mich sieht das aus wie so ein
schönes Stück Harrod cake oder so unten
hier das ist der Kuchen da oben haben
wir dann so einen schönen Frischkäse
Frosting drauf yummy das sind sogar
Streusel drauf ich wette mit euch das
sind echte essbare Streusel
jetzt nach Karotte wonach riecht kann
Grotte das gingerbrett
okay in Schaumbad ist es ist ein Ginger
bread House ja klar das hätte man kann
Werbung vs Realität
aus Frage ein gingerbrett Haus ist ein
Lebkuchenhaus
im Wort Ginger bread House steckt Ingwer
also denke ich mal dass da auch
irgendwie Ingwer drin ist im
Lebkuchenhaus ist doch aber kein Ingwer
drin oder sehr nett wenn du mir das
verraten könntet
gut dann nicht also ich verstehe nicht
warum es manche Produkte nicht gibt sind
die so exklusiv im Adventskalender ich
mache 8 Euro kommen wir zum wichtigsten
Türchen aller Zeiten das Türchen Nummer
guck mal das Türchen Nummer 9 hat was
Besonderes weil das Türchen Nummer 9
einfach das Beste ist und auf Tütchen
Nummer 9 steht mein Lieblingswort orange
Duschpeeling Zeit für Frische dieses
Peeling mit Meersalz enthält Orangen
voller Vitamin C sowie aufhaltende
ätherische Öle und sorgt für ein
strahlender und ich finde das Tierchen
Nummer 9 ist ein Zeichen dafür um weil
auszuprobieren und hier ist der Sticker
von dem ich gesprochen habe
gepackt am 25.07 du spielen Zeit
toll das ist intensiv bin jetzt eure
Verkäuferin also ihr nehmt einfach mal
so einen schönen Finger
ja ich vermute mal dass das noch orange
riecht
geil das Gefühl ist toll es ist auf
jeden Fall sehr Peeling mäßig man spürt
das Kratzen auf der Haut dabei gibt es
eine schöne weiche Komponente vom Zeug
und das ist einmal toll
also mein Badewasser für später das
Türchen Nummer 9 hat nicht enttäuscht
also diese Website sucht so langsam 8 €
Ansage weiter geht's mit Küche Nummer 10
da haben sie uns geties mit den ganzen
Dings ne jetzt komm hier die festen
Produkte hier ist so viel Glitzer drin
dass ich das da unten wie so bei
Apfelsaft Apfel sitzt kann man draußen
snow Ferry Duschgel ich glaube das packe
ich in die verlosungsbox das kann man
gut verlosen es riecht nach Kaugummi 9
€, ne Leute das könnt ihr gewinnen
macht euch bereit Nummer 11 was ist denn
jetzt los plötzlich kommen die ganzen
festen Produkte oh mein Gott jawollos
heutet Caramel Lippenpeeling oh mein
Gott solltet Carol macht ja so Sinn süß
und salzig damit du dich nicht
entscheiden musst hergestellt mit
goldenem Puderzucker und luxuriösen
Arganöl nimm einen kleinen Klacks auf
deinen Finger und poliere deine Lippen
Überschuss abtupfen eigentlich darf man
das doch ablecken das war doch mal das
Beste an diesen Lippenpeeling dass man
halt was drauf gemacht hat und danach
den
Türchen 11 kostet 11 Euro in den
Bewertungen sagt das einer das ist gut
schmeckt der andere sagt das ist noch
Seife schmeckt ich glaube man sollte es
aber gar nicht essen bei den Bewertungen
muss ich jetzt auf jeden Fall einmal
probieren auf meine Lippen kann ich
nicht machen denn ich habe
Lippenprodukte drauf
das schmeckt lecker ich will das jetzt
nicht Löffeln weil es ja auch nicht zum
Essen ist aber wenn ich das auf meine
Lippen bekommen würde finde ich das
nicht schlimm ich schließe mich der
erste Bewertung an schmeckt länger
Halbzeit meine Damen und Herren Halbzeit
oh glitzerparty nein das ist ja gut
gemeint ne aber diese diese Glitzer
Dinger schaut mal an wie toll das sieht
toll wenn man das anfasst kann man
gleich als Highlighter benutzen
jetzt bin ich auch ein glitzernder Gold
ich muss jetzt loslassen es ist mir zu
viel Glitzer Schleimi
woman's Max golden Angel Schaumbad und
Schaumbad für 8 €, ich sag mal so das
ist ein Schnapper Nummer 13 ein
Schnapper ist das sehen wir jetzt ein
festes Produkt heute okay jetzt bin ich
mir zu 100% sicher dass es in Polen
abgepackt wird Bogdan Bogdan und
jahrzeug und clash of ja das sind die
Polen
oh oh intensiv sehr
schwitzig witzig dieses würzige
Stärkungsmittel heißt deine Stimmung an
und verbesser deine Laune ja klar 11 €
ne hätte ich jetzt auch so ungefähr
geschätzt und damit haben wir die erste
Etappe geschafft vielen Dank an alle
Beteiligten
[Applaus]
ist das eine schöne Verpackung Runde
Nummer 2 schaut euch das an das ist das
Türchen Nummer 14 das größte Türchen bis
jetzt dann wollen wir noch mal sehen was
soll 5g noch mehr Verpackung erinnert
euch das auch ein bisschen angedärme
oh du heilige Badekugel
kommt mir gerade sehr groß vor ja die
ist schon auf jeden Fall größer du ist
die hübsch guckt euch das an und da ist
was drin
toller Duft draußen Pudding wild
Orangenöl Limettenöl orange Limette wie
ungefähr alles Glanz und Luxus 10 € für
Kugeln ich bin für sowas so zu haben
15 15 schwere Geburt mein Gott kommt da
doch raus ich liebe Schimmer ein kleines
Geschenk
was riecht komisch golden wonder Seife
es riecht nach Orange was soll ich euch
sagen es ist ein orange Adventskalender
7 € und was mit Orange verbirgt sich in
Türchen wo man rechts sehen cool 11
Shake von einem Elfen und Bock dann hat
sie wieder verpackte Duschgel
wildes Orangenöl und frischer Apfelsaft
reinigen nicht nur deine Haut sondern
eben auch deine Stimmung ja guck hier
steht was da so an Düften drin ist 100
ml kosten
11 Euro nein doch
17 ach haben wir hier mal wieder eine
traditionelle drin Diana klar ähm diese
Badekugel hat so ein Kristall Design
drauf ich finde ja diese Kuchen total
cool die Leute dann auch so Zucker so
verteilen dass es aussieht als ob so ein
aufgebrochener Kristallstein ist das ist
nicht mein Favorit Duft von links ich
glaube das was Minze ist Pfefferminzöl
ja Badebombe 6 Euro Leute super klasse
Nummer 18 na
ah natürlich ja
die war auch schon letztes Jahr drin ein
alter Klassiker Leute die Zuckerstange
obwohl das Zuckerstangen also ich habe
keine Ahnung wie man sonst hinkriegen
würde aber das hat er sonst so Streifen
eher und von der Menge wirklich nicht
viel ist das ein Schaumbad oder ist das
mehrfach Schaumbad das ist der Moment wo
wir mal wieder unser Wasser rausholen ja
wenn man es einfach ins Wasser schmeißt
passiert nichts also das muss man rein
machen wenn das Wasser gerade in die
Badewanne rein läuft
und da geht die Schaumparty auch schon
los ja das riecht doch mir hier schon
wieder
bergamottenöl Pfefferminzöl und
Zitronenöl ja es hat was Mercedes mann
das ist ein perfekter
Asien so richtig schön aus dem ermäßig
rundflanschen können
mehrfach verwendbar und 7,50 € nur
Nummer 19 wenn ich in so ein Lush Laden
reingehe habe ich manchmal schon so eine
Seite weil ich es nicht mag von
Verkäufern angesprochen zu werden
relativ schnell angesprochen
oh die riecht anders wollt ihr mal
riechen da ist ein kleiner Mond drin das
ist eine Seife bestimmt Christmas Eve
jetzt habe ich aber so ein kleines
Problem ich mag diese Papierverpackungen
bei und irgendeine Art von Verpackung
hätten sie sich schon überlegen können
weil jetzt ist das schon die dritte
Seife und ich würde das gerne halt vom
Staub also klar ich kann das jetzt
irgendwie selber aber so ein einfach so
ein Stück Seidenpapier oder irgendwas
was das war sie schützt weil ich kann ja
nicht drei Seiten gleichzeitig benutzen
in irgendeiner Form wäre das cool
gewesen wenn man eine Art Verpackung
hätte auch wenn sie Verpackung sparen
wollen
[Musik]
schade ich mache 7 Euro ich finde
Christmas Eve nicht 20 orange zum Essen
nein oh ja ich sag mal so ne der hätte
in das Türchen Nummer sechs rein gemusst
bin ich ehrlich der riecht gut oh sehr
frisch sehr sauber ganz klar Rosenholzöl
habe ich rausgerochen rote Beete Saft
klar und das Pulver himbeerpulver
absolut kaltgepresstes Karottenöl na da
haben wir endlich unsere Karotte magical
Santa am 24 kommen müssen 7 € Badebombe
ich sag mal hier haben wir wieder ein
klassischen Schnapper weil zu
Weihnachten oder davor verschenke ich
doch gerne so ein und dann kostet der
nur 7 €, wow twenty Bogdan do the Bogdan
der den ganzen Adventskalender gepackt
sleepy Bodylotion Male dir einen Traum
mit Pinselstrichen aus sanften
haferflockenaufguss und Lavendelblüten
oh das riecht ein
ich möchte sagen wie eine Sauna aber
nicht weil da irgendwie Leute es riecht
wie eine Sauna aber nach so einem
schönen Aufguss weil es ist halt
irgendwas holziges irgendwas frisches
was gerade so jetzt haben wir hier
wieder unseren QVC Moment
wo irgendwelche Leute eingecremt werden
kann gut Creme vertragen
[Musik]
und sind Tattoos immer eingecremt besser
aus weil die ganz ein bisschen strahlend
die ist toll
nee es riecht nicht nach Sauna es riecht
wie das vabali in Berlin im Kaminzimmer
wo es so richtig gemütlich riecht ja es
ist hammer also voll Lavendel die werde
ich mir definitiv nachkaufen 100 ml
kosten 14 das ist die Hälfte also 7 €,
aber echt wirklich eine sehr geile Creme
22 kein Problem leute guckt euch das
noch mal eben raus haben wir hier wieder
so einen kleinen Mistelzweig obendrauf
das ist doch das ruf doch Weihnachten
auch ein toller Duft sweet Pudding 6 €
nicht gut 23 ah da hauen sie noch mal
die Badekugeln raus und na klar
ist natürlich schwierig ne Leute da ist
jetzt hier auf dem letzten Meter ist der
Mond abgebrochen da konnte man wieder
fixen der Mann im Mond eine
Interpretation in einer Badebombe riecht
nach Orange 8 Euro wir sind endlich da
das 24 Türchen
Heiligabend oh ach ja bei denen gibt es
jetzt 25 also wir sind jetzt erst beim
vorletzten Türchen weil die Briten 25
Tage Adventskalender machen bei denen
ist halt Weihnachten erst am 25 bei uns
ist das ja schon Heiligabend das zähle
ich schon als das echte Weihnachtsfest
und jetzt sind wir beim echten
Weihnachtsfest das 24 Türchen du riechst
wie ein Lush laden und bekommst dein
kleines Geschenk für den Abend
von jetzige abgepackt
Schau mehr orange Handbalsam sweet wild
orange ist gerade nicht verfügbar ist
anscheinend super beliebt riecht okay
oder ja aber können wir mal was anderes
handbalsammäßiges weil ich will hier im
Preis 8 ja die verlose ich auf jeden
Fall denn ich habe wirklich sehr viele
Handcremes und jetzt sind wir beim
weihnachtstürchen das letzte wir rennen
runter oder rauf je nachdem wo sich euer
Kalender und ihr euch befindet und dann
öffnen wir und finden na klar natürlich
das Lush Parfum handgemacht mit feinsten
ätherischen Ölen
ich weiß nicht ob ich noch überhaupt
gerade was riechen kann
das ist stark ich sag euch wenn man sich
das draufsprüht man riecht wie ein Abend
auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt mit Feuer essen
also ich sag nicht dass es schlecht
riecht es ist nur so sehr herzhaft sehr
rauchig sehr gemütlich und ich habe
natürlich den Deckel angesprüht ich
Idiot jetzt bin ich gespannt was das
kostet wenn ihr das nächste Mal in einem
Lush Laden vorbeilauft geht mal bitte
rein riecht da dran und versucht mir zu
erklären wie das riecht ein Hirn ist so
überfordert damit so was kostest du 20 €
meine Damen und Herren und jetzt sage
ich euch wie es ist ich bin so gespannt
wie viel wie hier zusammenrechnen die
Spannung steigt die Zuschauer sehen
Vanessa dabei zu wie sehr ein paar
Zahlen in den ein Gerät reintippt und 35
kostet der und nicht haben 223 raus
[Musik]
also 12 Euro weniger als man ausgegeben
hat also erstmal danke für den
Adventskalender lass schnell ich liebe
ihn er ist toll ich liebe eure
Badekugeln also ich finde dass man
wenigstens genau das kriegen sollte was
man bezahlt hat und das so eine Box und
die schöne Verpackung und Top ist weil
man ja mit so einem Adventskalender ja
wie so ein rieseneinkauf tätigt also
dass man wie so ein bisschen so ein
Mengenrabatt kriegt und dieser Menge
Rabatt könnt ihr in dem Fall dann halt
so eine tolle Box sein hier auch schon
so seine 30 € Kosten kann das finde ich
aber wenn man quasi das zusammenrechnet
und ich habe es eigentlich ziemlich fair
ausgerechnet die Preise nicht schon dass
das halt drin sein sollte
ich noch sagen schöne Box nee auch
wirklich eine tolle Box ich gehe jetzt
was frühstücken und ich wünsche euch
einen schönen Tag habe euch lieb ne
behaltet die Ohren steif bleibt von den
Straßen Weg lernt was Gutes und dann
gutes Leben tschüss